all right so today's question comes from
annaleigh in nevada
italy writes i'm trying to get my
boyfriend and i out of debt
i only owe 28 000 in student loans
my boyfriend has almost eight times more
debt than i do but he thinks you can't
make money without spending it how do i
make him see that he's hurting himself
run get
a new boy run
[Laughter]
you can go left to california or right
to all the other states but run
you you can't um
ugh so here's a rule of thumb when
dating
do not date people you have to fix yes
or don't when you're in a relationship
and your thought is i have to
get us to that's the that's the problem
because us has to get us too
right his job is to initiate being a
grown-up
thus far he has not done that
yeah and he's not out he's i mean it's
not rare that people think
you gotta spend a whole bunch of money
to make money and what
i know that's common so i don't wanna
say he's an idiot he thinks you can't
make money without spending it right you
gotta spend money to make money no he
just says
you have to spend all the money you make
oh okay i always think she's in congress
no because there's been more than that
yeah there's been more than they made
yeah um apparently he does too
in what you can do in lee's you can sit
down and
and show him math and you can tell him
hey look i love you and you hurt
yourself
then the important part of that
conversation is is one that you're gonna
have to decide
are you in are you out and um you can't
help him you can't fix him you can't
heal him
he's gonna have to be a part of that
journey and you're gonna have to decide
do i want to walk with this guy through
his journey or not
um but you can't get you and your
boyfriend out of debt
no you can only get you out of debt and
you can show him how he
gets him out of debt so
um from a relationship perspective not a
financial perspective
if you were my daughter and i have grown
daughters that are married
i would say you'd sit down with this guy
and say
number one cause of divorce in north
america's money fights and money
problems
the fact that we're not in agreement on
this subject is going to end our
relationship
because i don't think i can make a life
with a guy who can't be responsible with
money and so i
in order for us to go forward i'm gonna
have to see you become responsible with
money
i'd be your cheerleader i can give you
some input
i can show you some things to do i
cannot do it for you
nor will i do it for you nor will we be
together long term
if you are not engaging in growing up
and that's a conversation from emily to
her boyfriend
the conversation annely has to have with
anna lee is i'm reading the tea leaves
here but this is somebody who struggles
with codependency this is someone who
struggles with
an identity that her value comes from
fixing other people
and i want annalee to do her work on
herself
and grow her value from the inside out
let that shine to the world because it
because we need her voice out there and
then she's going to attract people who
are not projects that are not
puzzles and or not engines who are
missing spark plugs
it's just an amazing way people attract
what they put out in the world
right let me ask you something i don't
disagree with that uh
you know you tend to um
it's not the victim's fault that someone
is a victim but there's even been
studies shown that
a rapist will pick a the way someone
walks
you just feel it yeah they're your
predators they're a predator and they
sense weakness
and they sense the body language in
other words and so
um you know and that's what you're
saying her body language is she has this
tendency to try to fix things and so she
takes in strays kind of thing um
and let's pretend for a second that it's
not that okay
that this is and we don't know her but
but just for the sake of uh
argument with our audience because we've
got a lot of audience in their early 20s
late teens especially on youtube and um
let's pretend that this is a 19 year old
young woman
okay and um
maybe she does feel okay about herself
but she just really likes this guy
and before she knows she's kind of in
love with him and then he has this
problem
yeah and he's a great guy and except for
except for and he and this is not like
you know normally she would not be taken
in straight normally she would not be
lacking in self-esteem normally she
would not be there
but she just kind of you know this guy's
they they've built a relationship but
and then all of a sudden she realizes oh
god this guy's got issues
so i i i was that's a little different
than i i'm attracted to okay
because i i have a pattern of always you
know bringing home losers yeah i read
this quote this weekend that
i was sitting on my front porch reading
dave and i stopped and it said sometimes
you have to have the courage to break
your own heart because it's the right
thing to do
and sometimes you've got to do something
so hard that's
the parent that says you cannot bring
drugs back into my home
yeah that is the girlfriend that says i
love you and
you're gonna drown us both and i'm not
gonna i'm not
i'm not gonna sign up for this because
this is gonna be a long horrible life
right and so this idea the the courage
and bravery it takes to say
i love you and i value
my ability to breathe but anali if
you're that person i'm talking about
not the one john was talking about a
minute ago that you're generally fairly
uh self-confident you need to know that
your desire for love in this particular
situation has flipped your language
out of the abundance of the heart the
mouth speaks your language says
codependence all over it
you know so let me kind of go back my
boyfriend has almost eight
times more debt than i do but he thinks
you can't make money without spending it
how do i make him see he's hurting
himself i'm trying to get my boyfriend
and i out of debt
yeah you me i'm gonna fix him i'm gonna
fix him i'm gonna fix him as well i says
over and over and over again
and there's a guy over there with a
backhoe digging holes and you've got
your shovel and you're like how do i
how do i fill it up and faster than he
can dig it up he can dig it faster than
you that's right yeah you're digging out
the bottom faster than you're ever going
to get there so i want you to put that
shovel down and go get some give you a
high
probability on this anally um as the old
guy
the that's a walking dead joke okay um
high probability is that if you are a
one young woman of confidence
and a good self-esteem uh that this
young man is not going to change fast
enough to keep you around
you're going to move on because i don't
think he's marriage material
i know he's not marriage material today
and it's because john
opened up with run and that was that was
his opening answer
was run and and i like to think of these
calls as what do i do if josephine
comes home from college says that i
found a guy right
yeah and dave you may not have
experienced this
and that's me being sarcastic i'm sure
you did but sheila had people sit down
and and talk to her
like are you sure you know what you're
doing with him right
like they would take her out kept
sharing away from those oh man they
found sheila
are you sure and she's like i'm sure um
her parents had to be rolling their eyes
when they
when i walked in i wouldn't let my
daughter date me oh not in a million
years
oh man i don't even go down that road
but so there is that right but
but um yeah but sharon did not take me
on as a project no
and i'd take her on as a project we were
both projects but we didn't take each
other everybody right but yes
sheila did not get her self-esteem by
saying i'm gonna fix john right yeah
it's just good parenting to run those
guys off if you have the opportunity
you know i'm just like daddy all the
boys in the youth group are scared of
you and i went good
keeps away two things wusses and jerks
don't need either one dating my daughter
that keeps away more than it keeps away
everything
wusses and jerks pretty well you put
most things in those two buckets
oh they're the same bucket well you know
there's some time
at times sometimes but it's just running
elite run